i don't have a lot of regrets in life
but there's a there's a um
there's a saying no regrets and i've
never understood it because i do have
regrets and one is
when we were doing our show at tbs you
contacted me
and
i i had no idea you were serious you
said i'd like to do the upholstery
i'd like to make you your talk show
couch
and i was like that's so hilarious man
that's great and then later on you're
like no no i was serious i would have
made your you would have made
that and i i felt like such an uh such a
lost opportunity to have a talk show
where jack white made
my talk show couch i'm looking at four
upholstered chairs right now it's not
too late
that's true yeah we should put you to
work but you were just fabric no welting
on the edges
sorry seriously this guy
first of all you did an apprenticeship
for how many years as an upholsterer oh
man many many years yeah i started when
i was 15 and i had my own shop when i
was 21.
then that's when the real learning
begins was when you open your own place
you know because you're like have nobody
to ask advice about anymore so right so
you opened your own shop did it do well
it did okay yeah but it did only sort of
i was so strange with it that it was you
know i was doing sculpture as well so
people were kind you know i i started
everything became an art form with me i
was feeling you know the insides of the
furniture with poetry and and you know
the the bills i was writing in crayon
like would be yellow paper with black
crayon and you owe me 300
and i would present it to them and i
delivered the piece
in the yellow and black uh uniform with
a yellow van that was the old part
detroit fire department van and it was
people were like
what
you know
it's like
you know people would probably would
have got return customers right right uh
some of these people
yeah no return customers but they would
pass my name on
and you i would just it seemed funny
because always got just enough uh money
from it to pay the bills it was never
any more than that it's always broke
even or less
um are there people out there
right now that have a couch that you've
put poetry in and they don't know it oh
yeah certainly oh right now people are
listening to this is just ripping their
couches
have you ever made like a leather
quilted door you know those yeah yeah
yeah i've done those button tough thing
it's called yeah and uh yeah button
tufting [ __ ]
no this is the first time you cut me off
before i could say it i'm an [ __ ] for
not saying that i'm sorry um yeah i mean
so you did that for a while and are you
you're obviously pursuing music at the
same time yes um
and that was kind of tough because i had
a studio so i was doing sculpture in
there like constructed sculpture and um
sort of carpentry based stuff and
garbage picking and putting that
together in sort of hardware store art i
was thinking of it being sort of
hardware store art and uh
working on furniture there for to pay
the bills and then also sometimes i
would bring a guitar in there too but
that usually was a mistake because i
would i would quit working on the
furniture and go and play guitar and
realize oh my god i've been playing for
two hours sitting here i should get back
to work
and um
yeah eventually that got to the point
where the white stripes got enough
offers to go and play shows that i i was
taken away from the furniture enough
that actually we started making enough
money
playing shows which was shocking to us
you know yeah and um
so
that that was that was yeah so then
eventually closed the shop up but but i
kept everything and i rebuilt it in
nashville behind my house
so i still have it now you have you see
do you still do it sometimes you still
do some upholstery to just kill people
oh yeah i did a lot of projects during
the pandemic the friction of 2020 the
first year of pandemic i worked on
nothing but furniture really and um let
me rephrase my question yeah do you take
commissions on leather buttons
at times